[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole n'a pas de pied mais elle
marche
voyage et ma parole à marcher la nuit ma
parole à marcher le jour ma parole à
marcher une nuit elle a marché un jour
ma parole à dévaler les pentes escarpées
des montagnes elle a défié les fines
herbes de la savane la parole à travée
d'immenses forêts profondes
elle invoquait sur la lagune ébrié se
mixer avec la lagune ou latine ma parole
à chevaucher le pont de la victoire pour
venir ce matin
au golden palace me présenter à vous
je suis laïc laurie fusée village
téméraires de la tribu de ceux qui
croient que la pierre
et le cheveu de vous parler la parole
qui vient du coeur de derrière moqueur
mais avant je voudrais qu'on salue
encore qu et ian carr sa parole a touché
mon coeur
puis la parole a touché mon coeur parce
que je commence en vo paroisse bien
évidemment vous avez dû le remarquer de
nourriture
de nourriture pour coire
écoutons cette petite histoire
l'histoire de ces deux petits garçons
qui sont quelque part
à la 7e tranche devant une maison cossue
et qui on sait qu'ils ont les entrailles
lacéré par le monde
à un moment donné
un majordome sort de la villa cossue
avec un plateau bien nourri
les ans on s'attend alors à festoyer
au moment où le monsieur
ouvre une poubelle que juste à côté et
puis il déverse toute la nourriture
au grand désespoir des enfants
parce que alors qu'ils pensent que le
monsieur va retourner dans la maison et
qui vont pouvoir se jeter sur la
poubelle pour ap ce repas copieux
malheureusement un véhicule de ramassage
d'ordures passe par la
déverse le contenu de la poubelle est
sans fin
combien de fois n'avons nous pas répéter
ce geste
au restaurant au maquis ou même à la
maison
des repas inachevé qu'on ne termine pas
et danton jette
le tiers et la
moitié les trois quarts
alors que quelque part sur cette terre
dans notre arc et dans notre ville dans
notre cité il y a des enfants des hommes
défunt qui
manquent du minimum pour satisfaire leur
être physique
c'est cela notre société 1 milliard 700
millions de tonnes
de nourriture
déversées dans les décharges
alors que 8 11 millions d'humains non
pas à marcher
surproduction
surconsommation mais en même temps
grande misère grand faim grande
désespérance
pourquoi ce mot là
l'humanité sur produit parce que l'homme
est dans une logique de surpuissance de
sueur domination
de sueur possession
tout ceci mû par une bonne valeur la
contre valeur de l'orgueil
l'orgueil humain
qui refuse de se contenter du peu qui
fait sur produits
pourquoi
en somme nos là à cause d'une autre
contre valeur l'égoïsme
l'égoïsme qui nous aveugle au point où
nous ne pouvons pas regarder autour de
nous et fois qu'il ya de la misère et
voir qui a la recette et foires qui lie
à la sécheresse
voilà où nous en sommes et c'est pareil
dans tous les domaines quand vous prenez
l'industrie de l'armement nous sommes
dans une logique de sueur armement parce
qu'on veut au lendemain poser à l'autre
on veut le battre et on finit par
l'abattre
voici où nous en sommes dans cette
société qui est devenue
une société je pense en faillite parce
qu'en même temps qu'on réalise de grands
progrès dans tous les domaines
nous sommes à la veille du metavers où
l'on va pouvoir se propulser par la télé
déportation dans toutes sortes d' espace
s'applique on réalise des performances
et nuit mais en même temps on n'est pas
loin de la bestialité avec cette
méchanceté
cet égoïsme
mon père jean tilly qui était on va dire
missionnaires du christ
puisqu'il partageait jusqu'à la dernière
pièce nous disait toujours à table
un seul bol de riz suffit à contenter un
homme a put tout ce qu on y ajoute est
superflu le docteur direct est
superfétatoire
super victoire
paraît que c'était inutile
mais l'homme hamas l'aube en crash
parce qu'il se pouvait sa force sa
puissance sa supériorité
un seconde
suffit
ça veut dire donc qui a un problème
d'éducation
éducation des yeux parce que c'est par
les yeux que la convoitise n'est
éducation du ventre
parce que c'est dans le fond de la
nourriture par
éducation de la conscience à ce qu'une
conscience altérée ne va pas accepter de
partage
un ce bol de riz suffit à nourrir un
adulte
ça veut dire donc on peut
comme l a fait partager
et en le faisant on va réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire
qui se fait partout pas seulement en
occident mais aussi
dans le contre et
ce qui est pire dans cette affaire c'est
que le gaspillage alimentaire
un effet négatif un impact sur le
dérèglement climatique
là il me dit pourquoi et bien parce que
les décharges
comme nous en avons dans notre pays est
certainement à grand bassam les
décharges produisent du méthane qui est
orga ce qui altère la couche d'ozone
donc à chaque fois qu'on jette de la
nourriture ruelle de la donner à un être
humain non seulement on prive quelqu'un
de de la subsistance mais en plus on
détruit l'environnement donc on a un
double effet dévastateur
et ça ça doit changer
genre tiens à dire que
le modèle de société de développer qu'on
nous a présentés
et peut-être jus la faillite de ce
modèle est peut être un modèle périnée
et qu'il nous faut au stade où nous
sommes arrivés
opérer une réflexion sur nous-mêmes
et faire de nouveaux choix
c'est à mon sens
le sens profond
de la pandémie qui a arrêté le monde
entier qui nous a bloqués dans les
aéroports dans les allées dans les gares
dans partout l'humanité critères
et on a vu l'a vu la vie pardon
reprendre
mais ce qu'on a fait l'effort surnom
de pousser la réflexion pour nous
demander au delà du virus
quel est le message qu'on nous envoie à
tant qu'humanité et bien ce message
c'est que nous devons rentrer en
nous-mêmes et changer passer du règne
des contre valeurs à une société des
valeurs et cela ça se construit par le
retour sur soi même je vous présente le
togo n'a qui est le palais et le
tribunal
l'espace où on procède au jugement en
pays dogon au mali
en
il ya eu comme une poussée dans mon
coeur j'ai eu envie d'aller aux manies
j'avais pas grands moyens j'ai pris mon
sac j'ai pris un ticket à la gare je
suis monté dans le car et puis 1000 km
je suis partie hommage je suis arrivé à
bamako et une famille la famille si c
est accepter de m'héberger
donc su rester auprès de maman si c'est
pendant dix jours et
sens pour moi mon séjour à bamako
coïncidait avec au cobaye à le grand
festival des cultures d'ogm et là j'ai
pu rencontrer le le oko by oko
qui m'a baptisé du nom de ogobara que la
gloire s'ajoute à la gloire alors
pourquoi je vous parle de dogo parce que
les deux corps sont une société avancée
les dogons ont découvert cyrus
la petite étoile blanche
que des sociétés
développées avec toutes leurs
connaissances en astronomie
n'ont pas pu découvrir les dogons il y à
2 2 2 3e avait déjà découvert cyrus par
un système d'observation qu'ils ont
écrit qu'ils ont mis en place là-bas
dans leurs falaises à bandiagara au mali
lors qu'une société
avance est capable de pester percer les
mystères de l'univers mais en même temps
une société de grande valeur parce que
le togo n'a que vous voyez est à à peine
un mètre vingt du sol quand on y va
quand on se réunit on est en position
assise et même pas vous avez un accès de
colère et de moules levé subitement
tac vous vous preniez la tête le togo
n'a vous dit de vous rabaisser parce que
vous n'êtes qu'un humain
et c'est comme ça que ça se passe le
pays dogon chef dirigeants ou simple
peuple vous ne pouvez pas vous élever au
dessous au dessus du taux cool
c'est un enseignement important et je
pense que beaucoup de nos dirigeants
devraient faire un tour dans un tournant
pour apprendre la loi de l'humilité
parce que c'est l'humilité qui nous
permet deux fois à l'autre pomme est
notre s'emballe semblables et donc de
lui accorder
terrey la considération le respect
qu'ils méritent le togo n'a donc une
société capable de produire au plan
scientifique technologique mais qui
reste très ancrée dans les valeurs
toujours un pays dogon il y à une
pratique qui consiste chaque année pour
les parents
à remercier a félicité les enfants et un
retour chaque année il ya une cérémonie
où les enfants les jeunes viennent
remercier et féliciter les parents ou
leurs bienfaits les époux remercie les
épouses et inversement les épouses
félicite et remercie les enfants le ch
est en train de vous parler de la valeur
de la pratique
une gratitude ce qui n'existe
pratiquement plus dans nos familles dans
nos maisons dans nos cités et mène d'un
dans nos services
où les gens sont plein de hargne
de colère de méchanceté d'agressivité
des choses qui me heurte au plus profond
de moi même parce que j'ai été éduqué
par mes parents à aimer l'autre exprimé
la gratitude à dire à l'autre qu'il est
beau qu'elle est belle sans l'intention
autre que de magnifier et de célébrer la
beauté qui en face de moi quand les
hommes apprendront à voir l'attitude
d'émerveillement devant l'homme devant
la création devant la nature
on opérera de très grands changements
parce que ce que vous admirez et mais
manifestement vous ne pourrez pas le
détruire né du perçu au bout est une
chose essentielle
et le togo n'a nous le rappelle
donc
sociétés développées vs société avancée
parce que la société de développer ce
modèle là est un modèle
en faillite mais c'est un modèle éculées
qui a épuisé ses ressources
aujourd'hui ils nous disent de revenir à
l'écologie l'écologie que mon grand-père
amodiations pratiqué dans son village ce
qui lui a permis de vivre jusqu'à cent
trente cinq ans
il avait des dettes des médecines
lui permettait de prendre soin de sa
santé
sa voix bio sont 135 ans de vie
quand on est allé annoncer
dans notre village schultz a dit que ça
aurait bien sont rentrés dans la
catégorie des centenaires et qu'on
allait lui organiser une cérémonie
ses frères qui sont restés à double y
ont commencé à rire
or mais on dit ça ouais après de fêter
son centième anniversaire mais en moins
900 comme ça
pour vous dire que ceux qui disaient ça
avait certainement au moins
150 ans
et dans ma langue il ya un mot pour
désigner celui qui a 200 ans c'est
l'union dont
le mien dans
une réalité existe dans une langue c'est
que elle a existé dans cette langue ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire donc que
chez nous on vivait au moins jusqu'à 150
chansons
et des gens sont venus un matin pour
nous dire
que nos sociétés sont de la société
hariri que nos murs des mondes pénis
que nos valeurs sont des valeurs sûres
années et qu'il faut tout changer tout
balayer qu'il faut embrasser le
développement
qu'il soit en lacets la modernité mais
de quelle modernité est-ce qu'on en
parle de quel développement est ce qu'on
n'est pas lorsqu'on détruit les fleuves
et les rivières l'autre kaspi la
nourriture l'offre comprend des arbres
pour aller faire la guerre au mahdi
contre nos frères
lequel développement espoir
et voilà nous en sommes à la fin à
l'éléphant
je parle de l'effort
qui est là des mâles totem de la côte
d'ivoire et j'en parle au moment nous
sommes à bas à grand-bassam la terre
d'écran commencement il ya cent
vingt-neuf ans que la côte d'ivoire
était fondée ici
cent vingt neuf ans après faisons le
bien et nous nous rendrons compte
que ce bilan n'est pas aussi élogieux
que les pères fondateurs lors souhaité
dans l'hymne national
je ne pourrai pas aller plus loin mais
retenons simplement qu'à ce stade de mon
discours nous avons le choix entre à m
l'éléphant qui boit de 100 kg 200 litres
de belley équité du tout autour de lui
ou les efforts héroïques qui ont battu
les fennecs récemment cet anneau de
choisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]